Entertainment Weekly has been working
hard not too long ago they gave us our
first look at Aquaman and earlier this
week they gave us our first look at
Shazam but something even more exciting
is that today they gave us a better look
at venom not only did they give us an
awesome brand new photo but they also
gave us Tom Hardy's thoughts on playing
the character the first photo that they
gave us is of doctor Drake and Tom
Hardy's character Eddie Brock strapped
down to a chair without the context of
the situation it's really hard to say
what this is but no doubt it has
something to do with the symbiote it's a
cool picture but let's get on to the
next one
this picture is awesome it's the most
detailed photo that we've got of venom
so far and it's creepy which I love
venom is a violent character he's a
really violent character actually and it
seems like they're going to do him
justice in this movie it seems like Tom
Hardy thinks so as well let's take a
look at some of the things the actor had
to say about playing Eddie Brock slash
venom when interviewed by Entertainment
Weekly Tom Hardy said as far as Marvel
characters I have to say for me venom
looks the coolest that sounds a bit
shallow but I appreciate that he has a
kind of brazen swagger and a zero
Foxtrot attitude he then goes on to say
there's a tragic clown element which I
find funny and is harmonious with some
of the work that I like to do there's
something funny about the circumstances
of having a gift but it's a tragic gift
it's a superpower you don't really want
but at the same time you love it it
makes you feel special
he's a reluctant hero and an antihero
they then go on to talk about the
difference between Jekyll and Hyde and a
werewolf stating that a werewolf is kind
of two different people it's the human
that transforms into the werewolf and
with the case of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
Jekyll and Hyde are again two different
people Jekyll transforms into Hyde but
unlike these characters venom and Eddie
Brock don't really switch back and forth
from one another instead they occupy the
same body at the same time and they have
to learn to coexist
speaking of this Tom Hardy said we
talked a lot about a werewolf and what
it is when you get infected or bit by a
werewolf usually a human gets imbued
with powers or an alien comes from outer
space and has to figure out how to live
on earth but this is really about a
relationship between two people who have
to work together to create this hybrid
symbiotic relationship and the duality
of the role is actually what really
fascinated Tom Hardy into playing the
character he says it's a bit like Ren &
Stimpy you know they have different
sounds I always saw venom as sounding
like a James Brown lounge lizard and
Eddie Brock is kind of a I don't know an
everyday kind of God but he's inherited
this massive ego this beast the result
of this is of course a black and white
hero whose morals are anything but that
of a hero and which Tom Hardy says
there's that biting off heads issue
which is not what you would expect from
say Captain America taking down a crook
so from this interview it sounds like
Venom's gonna be the real deal they're
gonna stick true to the character which
includes the violence
I actually really hope there's a scene
where then a bite somebody's head off so
that's it for the new photos that we've
received and the interview with Tom
Hardy from Entertainment
let me know what you think of the photos
and the interview and what you're most
excited about when venom comes out be
sure to like the video and be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on all things Marvel DC and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]